Yeah.
Working in Africa,
I'm very conscious that there are 53
countries and that they are moving at
different speeds.
And the two also have important Pan
African and regional African
institutions.
Uh,
there was a reform of the African Union
and it has a commission,
like the commission of the European
Union.
Half the members of that commission are
women.
So there's a big commitment to gender in
m a lot of issues in many of the
countries.
Now,
there is a real sense that things are
moving forward.
And there was a recent Pew opinion,
uh,
sampling taken and most of the African
countries sampled,
really felt there's a lot of room for
improvement,
but we're on the right road commitment
to the Millennium Goals,
better governments tackling corruption.
So I think there's a tendency sometimes
to sort of write off Africa and a sweep
as being a basket case or something far
from it.
Now they're actually very interesting
and very progressive things happening in
many of the countries in Africa.